hi Simon will leads here and I am out in
London the cost of coffee with the
auction king it is mr. Piazza
so so in this interview you can learn
all about auction properties so stay
tuned
okay so let me welcome you to the first
things that a lot of people certainly
are used to think about auctions blanket
is cheap from an auction is a myth
because in auctions people get greedy so
what would you say you need to know how
to buy properties well and the auction
because it's easy to get emotionally
attached to property and then options
are set up in such way that if you want
to offer a lot of money you can do that
very quickly a lot of people fall for
that so a lot of people over place for
properties in the auctions but there are
certain properties that people are
scared of or they don't know how to
solve certain problems and you can get
really good deals on those properties if
you know how to solve problems and if
you know how to okay that's great I mean
would you be able to just tell us a
little bit about how you got into
property and give us a feel for I mean
you don't sound like you from England
actually originally for all ins
Poland excellent excellent so how do you
transition from living in Poland to
being a successful property investor in
England and so that was quite long and
twisted journey and I came to the UK 12
years ago and my dream was to study in
in the UK and actually one of my
universities of chose Aberdeen for
various reasons and I want to study in
Aberdeen about 11 years ago I gradually
from that animals come to London to find
a job and before coming to London I went
for a 10-day silent meditation retreat
and over that I met someone who offered
me a job in properties in London and
sourcing properties for investors in
London so you started off just working
as a job as a nanny exactly what we do
exactly and so how'd the my first dog
was go to auctions and look at what's
happening and speak to investors who
bought properties offer them some
brokering services or bridging guarantee
so that was my first couple of months
they had a job working in auctions yeah
we've got auctions yes I it's a that was
my first experience of auctions was six
years ago and then our my long time of
transition and ours
speaking of agents trying to find deals
in Paddington made of our son John
school to those areas yeah and we had
full of investors who are looking for
the properties there and we kind of had
like a turnkey solution but find a
property find tenants manage them and
that would be my kind of role that's
excellent
yes I was a really good training in in
basic property fundamentals
yeah so you told me another time the
bowing from estate agents is like
playing a football
you're both of auctions is like playing
basketball yeah and those laws are very
different what are the key differences
between buying from an estate agent or
and yet so the key differences is and
the fact that in the auction when you
make an offer that offer you need to
basically follow it up with a 10%
deposit pretty much straight away yeah
so in the ocean you get a legal park in
advance you get everything in advance
and you do diligence and then you need
to pay the deposit as soon as you make
an offer yeah and that's basically the
main difference so the process is really
quick it's streamlined and the sellers
are totally committed to sell the
property because they already signed the
terms with that option yeah and if they
withdraw it they have to pay the fee we
see they don't want to pay the fee to
sell the property so don't think twice
about signing the terms and conditions
and movin estate agents you get people
who basically test the market they try
to put a party at a certain price if
they can get it and usually it's a
really hard price in the option
everything starts really low because it
starts with the reserve so the minimum
amount as the seller is preparing to
sell for and that is usually quite low
so then in the auction that price kind
of goes up so when you make enough of an
auction property they tend to be above
the gyda price
yeah and estate agents you know know you
make an offer below the asking price yes
so that is the kind of main difference
it's a totally different dynamics
yeah like you said different sports of
different knows each other and say
estate agents is that one sport
auctions is a different sport even
though this property is a common thing
like a board could be common thinking in
different sports but it also different
you know how to play different notes
that's great so if you were to go to an
auction yeah what kind of all to be the
best
would it be a property you found on
Rightmove and then it's for sale by
auction or is a different one and so
their various ways you can obviously
land when you find a property on right
movement it's in the ocean and then you
go to that auction or you can do a
little bit more structured about this if
you know you won't find something in the
auction you can either follow an option
that's your local ocean and review the
catalogues go to the ocean have a kind
of like a local looks like what the
process is like and or you can sign up
for if you want to let them take it to a
next level
you can sign up to essential information
group that's a comport oh it's like
right now for auctions all the
auctioneers of that all the ocean
properties are there and you can see
everything on your screen basically in
one place easy to find
so that's why I use for finding
properties I use a I hope because it
just makes it streamlined and easier
must be I group that code that you guys
are thinking that's the address you can
find the dock and it's called essential
information so you're on yo a group
you're looking at the properties or your
arrival ooh yes
what specifically are you looking for
and so I'll be looking at properties
that have potential to add value and
properties that potentially can be
problematic because I like properties
that would put other people off yeah and
we know how to solve the problem
with other people off then we don't
really have that much competition in the
buying process so that's what kind of
problems it could be at a freehold house
converted into three flats by the seller
ten years ago 20 years ago and that's
never had panic some people don't know
how to deal with those properties but we
know everything from the legal point how
to solve those problems so we are able
to buy properties like that with
confidence that we can get the planning
okay and that basically means that we
have less competition and we can buy
properties that's another thing that's a
little bit risky though because if
you're buying properties where the owner
has given up trying to get planning
permission or whatever it is there's a
big problem and then given up and then
you're taking on that problem unless
you're pretty damn confident that you
can solve the problem
is that not a bit risky could you think
is badly burned with that strategy and
it's up on the face of it it looks risky
but and enough that I know knowledge
it's it's just a matter of following the
process and obviously every property
transaction is risky even if you buy
from this
it is risky it's just the risk are not
sore point in options those risks are
more sort of exposed than I than
especially if you've got to pay a
deposit up front yeah I mean what kind
of due diligence would you do before
going to an auction definitely I would
check the property history on the a
group so yeah Group offers like history
going back 25 years ago human Street or
given property so we can see with our
property majority in the auction we can
see what it's sold for in the past and
whether it was withdrawn whether it was
unsolved so that this is the first thing
the house check and then I will check
the planning history what's in the
planning history whether you're spinning
the records I would check whether these
surprises for the problem that flux that
we could get in that property and what
the GDP is and then I'll calculate the
cost about end up with the price are you
happy to pay yeah that makes sense so
you've got do quite a lot of due
diligence before going to an auction yes
yeah and how do you how do you check if
you if it's a property and it's
currently being used as three flats yeah
and you're thinking the you need to get
planning permission but the current
owner hasn't or can't get planning
permission how do you check whether you
can definitely get loose over well I
don't want to leave in all my trade
secrets but there's certain steps that
you can take with property like that so
one is in to check for how long this
property's been like that if it is over
four years and there's been no
enforcement notices then there's
likelihood that you will be able to get
funding on it they need to check whether
this property's been used like that for
continuously for over four years and if
it was and if it's called like separate
meters or
can proven with bills tenancy agreements
then there is a certain process that you
can go through the planning that will
allow you to get the funding basically
yeah
so this bill or that for more than four
years yeah it's usually very easy to get
planning permission that's correct yeah
there we go little tip where we're
getting all his secrets for now we're
passing them out yeah I know pulling it
off so what would you say the main
advantages to buying from an auction are
vers buying off market or through the
stacked engine so one thing as the
properties are being offered very low
prices
usually there are twenty to thirty
percent discount
yeah estate agent if there is no
competition so those are the main things
that I would say critical and from my
experience as well for buyers it's
really good that the transaction happens
quickly and all the information are
presented upfront because as long as we
do our work and normally we do our work
then we know that the deal is that yeah
another question is all no guy and his
strategy is to buy rental properties
from right yeah and then put them on an
auction and greedy builders getting to
bidding wars and they end up selling for
more an auction than they would
but you know one question is how do you
distinguish between an auction motivated
seller when you're gonna be able to get
a good discount verbs an auction seller
who is just trying to get the maximum
they can and it's just going to be
surrounded the room is gonna be filled
with macho bidding war type people how
do you how do you make sure that you
don't end up wasting your time go to
auctions whereby they end up selling for
much more narrating one main thing is no
one knows even yourself I think they
can't guess what the property is gonna
be like in the ocean some properties
seem very quiet and then there's two
people bidding for it twice that the
guide price yeah and some property seem
quite busy and many people and so one of
the main things that I do to protect
myself from what he said wasting time
going to auction and I'm losing the
bidding yes that's not only what happens
in my case I would maybe 5% auction
bidding in the room so I focus on buying
properties before the audition that is
place where if it's a promised well and
then we send professional office then
it's easier to gather properties okay
excellent
so if you go to an auction you're gonna
have a maximum price that you'll go to
you don't go above that all yes even
even a little bit how strict are you 150
pass but you're pretty nice if research
on it yeah please sleep maybe we can go
okay you know you're not gonna go away
about what
sign it but usually you're gonna try and
buy a property before auction day yes
how do you do that how do you do the
owners and the ages not to say arrive on
the day I mean how do you put together a
professional author which is going to be
considered or even accept it without
sending them to the auction yeah well
that all starts with understanding our
wishes work and what the seller
motivations are to seven years and the
various type of solid solution there are
private sellers into the ocean basically
not to get the best price over they want
to get the best price but they're asking
myself I stated but what they want is
they want transparency that's the main
thing
so those type of sellers would never
accept the offer because but private
service or receivers they can accept
pre-auction office because they know
they have certain goal in mind and if
the offer is in line with the goal then
they might just take it all day risking
the property being sold in the auction
at the reserve price yeah so we tend to
offer someone we think sure so if the
reserve price is 200 thousand mo
opportunity
correct outside of the auction do you is
it a numbers game or do you specifically
target service and sellers so we target
certain service and it's a numbers game
yeah because even the seller even with
this in mind except the auction off the
day now how do you find those oh sure
sure so you're gonna find properties
that you like you're gonna make sure
they're links on privately yeah and then
you're gonna write to them and not for
it oh yes is there a particular skill to
putting in the offer is there a
particular wording that you can use and
I think it's not so much about the
wording is about conveying that you are
ready to exchange to show so the way you
make up for the auction is like any to
have done your due diligence and then
coming in making offer say we want to
buy this for two hundred twenty thousand
we are ready to announce we declutter so
you can afford the property like you
gotta make sure it's been so private
right the energy videos what does your
due diligence typically consist of and
as I said before
[Music]
so you can just do that bellowing all
the websocket anything else and I'll
check all the right information yes
so your father sold houses to see how
much it's worth yes
the rentability yes do you actually view
the policy before you offer and we don't
hear this property yes yeah so if a
property is on an auction yeah
can you still just go and do it for a
moment yes you can
so your view and hoody normally be with
you bring a bill or do you go on your
own and it depends on property for how
to bring someone I know for myself
yeah and then do I like to use yes I can
come back to whatever I waste or show it
to someone who I think should see
yeah excellent so so chaos you've given
a lot about you so far about auctions
and how to find properties from an
auction
how do you do diligence give us an
example of what typical case study might
look like
what's your property from an auction
okay so there was a property that came
over tonight there was where to check
ways of the tenancy agreement and we
have to check the legal part was set and
the specific conditions because special
conditions are the key element of each
style and the auction and we checked
what terms of the sale and we check what
the cell values would be latent located
actually ages and we also checked with
building professionals how much so there
was all that reduces from the legal
aspects on the distal aspects and also
making it okay so what would the figures
how much did you buy for what were the
earthly figures as some property was
purchased for two hundred ninety
thousand yep there was including all
purchased we spent 65
[Music]
yes so so the final myth is about 575
investor it's just coming to sell it and
[Music]
that's incredible so I'll go make
Olympic a or make fifty seven thousand
pounds per year
gross that's correct awesome well you've
given a lot of value you've spoke about
how to find properties on auction what
web for us to use what do diligence to
look for what kind of problems to look
for yes apart from title splitting so
you mentioned about how there could be a
problem they can't get planning
permission and what are the problems
could could there be a no problem could
be no building control that sinus
[Music]
so how do you find properties with
problems does it normally stay on the
roids up what the problem is not so the
problem usually comes up do the due
diligence process and also looking at
what the lenders would require to
finance the property so what was in the
description no it's not oh just take
some real work Thanks so what would you
say to someone watching this video
who's think him 48 ground in six months
not bad
and they would love to get into buying
from auction but they've never done it
don't know where to start what your
first steps initial advice and and the
advice could be just don't educate
yourself what advice would you give so
one thing is definitely do some dry
lands and oceans yes feel for it and
definitely speak with someone who don't
know is before because they'll have
experience they've done mistakes they
experience some things that you might
not want to go into and and also get
lawyers and kind of you poverty in that
is coming your focuses process and we
also educate yourself and get the
fundamentals of options right and with
that you'll be able to find your own
answers incredible if someone wants to
get in touch with you what's the best
way to contact you at the various ways
they can find me on LinkedIn
peel through snack and they can find me
on Facebook of the same name and also
I've got a YouTube channel option news
TV that people can find me on and
there's my website company websites
energy
I find people calm synergy - PP calm so
check it out
I hope that's been helpful a lot of
certainly lot learnt a lot having
breakfast with you and Jamie three right
now so thanks ever so much
Shane too much Samia and I'll see you
soon
[Music]